this photo represents a historic moment
for wildlife protection in the us
four u.s cavalry soldiers posing with
eight
severed bison heads in yellowstone
national park
it was taken in 1894 after the capture
of a notorious
poacher in the park ed howell soldiers
caught him in the act of skinning the
animals to sell their hides
surrounded by the carcasses of bison
he'd killed
yellowstone had just been established
around 20 years earlier
and was a refuge for the american bison
or buffalo
whose population numbering in the
hundreds was on the brink of extinction
hal's capture led directly to the first
u.s federal law protecting wildlife
and the photo of the confiscated heads
was meant to depict the soldiers as
heroic defenders of an endangered and
beloved
american icon but it also shows what
drove the bison to near extinction
in the first place the u.s government
itself
[Music]
this was the bison's approximate range
before 1800
covering a significant amount of north
america by 1870
the population had been reduced to these
two great herds
by 1889 american bison numbered in the
hundreds
down from tens of millions at the
beginning of the century
and the reason for their destruction
becomes clear when you add this to the
map
the tribal lands of the plains indians
you cannot overstate the importance of
the buffalo to the people of the
northern and southern plains
dean angelia whitaker is a lecturer on
american indian studies whose research
focuses on issues of environmental
justice throughout u.s history
the buffalo has been central to these
cultures
for hundreds of years and the buffalo
provides everything it's not just food
but it's everything needed for everyday
life
plains tribes constructed dwellings from
bison heights
used bison blankets for warmth and the
bones
for tools most important of all was
bison meat
the crucial food source for the
indigenous peoples of the great plains
there is absolutely everything about the
buffalo
that makes this animal central to these
cultures which is why the u.s government
wanted them wiped out
completely white settlers in north
america
adhered to a cultural belief known as
manifest destiny
the idea that white people were destined
to expand west on the continent
conquer the landscape and develop it
manifest destiny is most famously
depicted in this 1872 painting
called american progress which shows the
expanding railroad
following a steady stream of settlers
westward
and the land's native inhabitants
including the bison
fleeing into darkness imagery like this
depicts the transformation of the land
as a natural one
rather than the brutal reality of native
people's forced removal
by the time it gets a name to it
manifests destiny in the 1840s
the u.s is engaging in very violent
processes
of pushing native people off their lands
to make those lands available for
settlers
and native people resisted it which
meant war
for the u.s a key part of that war was
eliminating the bison population
the extermination of the buffalo was
central to manifest destiny
they knew that you go after the buffalo
you can subjugate the people you can see
clear evidence of this plan
in statements made by army officials at
the time like general philip sheridan
who said the best way for the government
is to now make them poor
by the destruction of their stock and
then settle them on the lands
allotted to them and in a letter to
sheridan
fellow u.s general william tecumseh
sherman suggested a way to accomplish
that
it would be wise to invite all the
sportsmen of england and america
for a grand buffalo hunt and make one
grand sweep
of them all throughout the rest of the
19th century
that's exactly what happened the bison
was hunted excessively for entertainment
and competition both by the us cavalry
and amateur hunters bison hunting
parties would shoot at herds from
passing trains
in what was called a sport that is
peculiarly american
bison were also killed for commercial
profit to satisfy
an enormous desire for their skins and
bones in eastern cities
these hunters would kill bison by the
dozens for their skins alone
leaving the carcasses behind to rot by
the end of the 1800s
there were almost no bison left
by the time that happens native people
are
confined to reservations this forced
submission means that they
have to rely on the federal government
for food as part of
a program of forest assimilation
once native people have been confined to
reservations
the government set aside some of the
cleared land for a national park
and yellowstone was established in 1872
the yellowstone park act designated the
land as a pleasuring ground
for the benefit and enjoyment of the
people all of these parks
are predicated upon the disappearance of
native people
it's about preserving it and making
these destination
places for the well-to-do white settlers
preserving the so-called natural wonders
of the park
included protecting the few remaining
bison roaming there
the same us government that had driven
the animal to near
extinction in the first place now
positioned itself as the guardian of the
endangered species
and the us army who occupied yellowstone
in its early years
patrolled the park in search of bison
hunters
which is where this photo comes in it
was taken by frank j
haynes the official yellowstone
photographer at the time
who encountered the soldiers bringing ed
howell into custody
and photographed them posing with the
bison heads they found in bags
hanging from a tree the story of hal's
dramatic capture
put the issue of poaching in yellowstone
into the national spotlight
less than 60 days later a federal law
made hunting in the park
illegal marking the beginning of
wildlife protection legislation
in the u.s american bison are no longer
endangered
and yellowstone's website upholds house
capture by the us army
as having saved the bison in yellowstone
but the staging of this photo also
perpetuates the idea of manifest destiny
it portrays agents of the us government
as virtuous guardians of the environment
choosing to overwrite their own role in
destroying it
there's no better representation for
this
highly romanticized story about what
america is
it's not the reality of the incredible
violence
of this historic process toward native
people and toward other species
one thing that's super interesting about
the initial article detailing ed house
capture
which published in forest and stream
magazine in 1894
was the photos they used three photos
showing groups of slaughtered bison
each one captioned the butcher's work
paired with the story
the implication here is that the butcher
is howl and
these are the bison that he killed but
there's no photo credit attached
probably because these photos weren't
taken in yellowstone
and they were published seven years
earlier in an 1887 smithsonian survey
called the extermination of the american
bison by william t hornaday
hornaday was an early american
conservationist and his research is also
where the data for the map at the
beginning of this episode
showing the destruction of the bison
population came from
there's a link to the full survey in the
description of this video and if you
want to read about this story in more
detail
including how photography and fine art
played a role in shaping our memory of
the origins of us national parks and
wildlife protection
check out poaching pictures by alan
braddock it's a fascinating read
and interviewing professor braddock was
a big part of the research for this
episode
so keep an eye out for more darkroom to
come and thanks for watching